dans cette ferme de saint-eustache les
cueilleurs s'activent depuis le 2 juin
les fraises du québec sont de retour
elles sont même en avance d'une bonne
semaine
on a eu de très beaux klimov chaud au
début de mois au pire on peut dire qu'on
sort des gros volumes présentement le
dos fraises au québec louis bélisle est
un des plus gros producteurs de la
province
il emploie habituellement 120
travailleurs étrangers
ils ne sont que 80 pour l'instant
surtout des guatémaltèques
il ne pense toutefois pas manqué de
cueilleurs pour l'été contrairement à
plusieurs producteurs d'aspergés qui ont
dû le faire une croix sur une partie de
leur récolte des gens d'aspères jose on
commence très tôt début de l'année le
travail avec dams et avec le travail à
ça rentrait pas tout mais ça c'est se
placer comme celle de sa voix très bien
vous je vois pas de problème pour la
venue en fait la seule grande crainte
ici c'est qu'un travailleur attrape la
queue vide
on fait vraiment attention nos employés
ils vont pas faire leur épicerie travail
jeu ça la ferme du travail partie gros
dos m sa distance et les pièces
en cette année de pandémie il y a quand
même un avantage les québécois plus que
jamais veulent acheter local chez cet
autre producteur à mirabel
le kiosque venait d'ouvrir pour la
première fois vendredi
vous l'attendiez mais pourquoi parce que
c'est moi je trouve que c'est la place
pour lui ça mais le sort de la figure du
bon goût dans la bouche
les fraises du québec sont meilleurs de
californie d'autres depuis deux semaines
que des gens veulent savoir quand est ce
qu'on va commencer
c'est tellement motivé je vous dirais
alors de dire il faut continuer il faut
pas lâcher
ou c'est un peu plus dur cette année
mais la résilience on endort 80% des
travailleurs que pierre rivet ti
embauches viennent du québec
sauf qu'en s'étendent coronavirus avec
ottawa qui offrent 1250 dollars par mois
aux étudiants
il craint lui aussi de manquer de main
d'oeuvre ont déjà des répercussions
effectivement des appels déjà qui vous
permettra donc moins marché fait que oui
ça ça peut être un peu plus difficile
mais soyons positifs ça va bien aller
dylan à 17 ans il travaille pour lui
depuis quatre ans déjà
je pense que je vais en gagner plus en
faisant ça ici que c'est chez moi avec
la piscine je fais quelque chose à mes
journées je reste pas dans le sous sol
chez nous à rien faire comme si d'un
fonds de deux mandats en masse pour
finalement accueillir tout sort dé prix
seront un peu comme les autres années
sinon on risque ça risque d'être un peu
plus cher
il invite donc les québécois allaient
travailler dans les champs sur sa ferme
par contre pas d'auto cueillette cet été
en raison du virus
une majorité de producteurs devraient
toutefois la permettre ici
jean-sébastien cloutier radio-canada
mirabel